Let's not kid ourselves: we already all know
that The Last Jedi is going to melt your brain
when it appears in theaters in December, 2017.
After The Force Awakens revitalized the Star
Wars franchise at the movies in 2015, there
was little doubt that the follow-up would
probably be pretty amazing.
But now that we've gotten our first real look
at the movie via the debut teaser trailer,
we can say with some certainty that Episode
VIII will take us places we never even knew
we wanted to go.
Here are just a few of the reasons why Star
Wars: The Last Jedi will blow you away in
December.
Rian Johnson’s sci-fi cred
When it comes to Hollywood's current crop
of go-to directors, Last Jedi director Rian
Johnson may not necessarily be a name that
everyone recognizes immediately.
But ask any fan of Johnson, and they'll tell
you he's been helming incredible flicks with
consistent regularity for years.
For example, if you haven't yet checked out
2012's Looper, written and directed by Johnson,
do yourself a favor and make sure you watch
it as soon as possible.
Johnson took a relatively low budget and produced
one of the more memorable and impressive science
fiction movies in years.
Just imagine what he can pull off with the
might of Disney's wallet backing him up.
Lots of Luke
One of the chief complaints about The Force
Awakens was that Luke Skywalker, the hero
at the center of the first Star Wars trilogy,
was pretty much absent for the entire movie
— right up until the very end.
The lack of Luke makes sense in the context
of the film, of course, since finding him
is one of the movie's main objectives.
But some fans couldn't help but be disappointed
that one of the franchise's most important
characters was barely there.
Now, though, Skywalker's truly back.
The new movie seems to have no shortage of
the former farmboy: in this trailer alone,
he presides over some lightsaber training,
hangs out with R2-D2, and even chills near
the mouth of a cave!
In short, fans are going to be up to their
armpits in Luke Skywalker — and that fantastic
beard of his.
If you love Luke — and you obviously do
— your prayers have finally been answered.
Captain Phasma’s return?
When fans weren't wondering why there wasn't
more Luke in The Force Awakens, they were
probably complaining that Gwendoline Christie
was painfully underused as the shiniest stormtrooper
of them all, Captain Phasma.
She yelled at Finn, talked to her boss that
one time, then got dumped into a trash compactor.
"Aghh!"
Would that really be all we got of the Captain?
As it turns out, no, it wouldn't.
We only see her for a moment in the new trailer,
but unless the First Order has started handing
out shiny stormtrooper outfits to anyone who
asks, that's Phasma.
What she's doing in The Last Jedi is, of course,
totally unknown, but it's good to know she's back.
Rey of light...or dark
In a revelation that should surprise exactly
no one, The Last Jedi will finally start to
answer some of the questions about Rey that
fans have been asking since she first showed
up in The Force Awakens.
Speaking during the 2017 installment of Star
Wars Celebration, actress Daisy Ridley said,
simply, "What I can say is, in The Last Jedi,
we go deeper into Rey's story."
It was always a given that the hints of Rey's
origins and destiny we saw in the previous
movie would get more exploration in the follow-up.
Now that she's been training with Luke Skywalker,
she may make some discoveries about herself
and where she really came from that could
shock her — and fans — to the core.
Speaking of which...
Shades of Empire Strikes Back
It's an oft-repeated truism, but you can never
say it too many times: The Empire Strikes
Back is the best installment in the Star Wars
saga.
So it's exciting to see that The Last Jedi
seems to be going in a similar direction.
Need proof?
There's a moment in the new trailer where
a bunch of ships are speeding toward a confrontation
with a marching battalion of walkers — just
like what happened on Hoth during the first
act of Empire Strikes Back.
Then there's the serious struggle our heroes
will have to endure and overcome, another
hallmark of Empire.
Take, for instance, the scene where Poe Dameron
and BB-8 are racing towards their X-Wing,
only to recoil from an explosion.
Now, remember how Luke got his X-Wing stuck
in the mud on Dagobah?
Or how the Millennium Falcon's hyperdrive
just kept malfunctioning?
We only have the barest threads of The Last
Jedi's plot to speculate with, but it seems
like this new movie aims to echo many fans'
favorite Star Wars movie in plenty of ways.
Hello, Rose
While Rey is sequestered away as Luke's student,
Finn and Poe will need another ally.
While she doesn't seem to appear in the trailer,
Rose will be the new character to take on
that role.
Variety reports that actress Kelly Marie Tran
will appear in The Last Jedi as a maintenance
worker in the Resistance who joins Finn as
he gets into his latest round of galactic hijinks.
Outside of that, we don't know a whole lot
about Rose, though Johnson did say this at
Star Wars Celebration:
"She’s not a soldier [...] She’s not looking
to be a hero, and she gets pulled a very big
way into an adventure in this movie with Finn
[John Boyega]."
As to what else we can expect from Rose in
The Last Jedi, it's way too soon to tell.
But it's pretty exciting to know that there's
a whole new major character coming that didn't
even make it into the trailer.
Imagine what other surprises and twists were
left out...
Farewell, Princess
Despite the excitement that comes with a new
Star Wars movie, it's hard to forget that
actress Carrie Fisher passed away in late
2016, leaving a hole at the very heart of
the saga itself.
We know that Fisher finished filming her scenes
for Episode VIII before she died, and we catch
a glimpse of Leia in the new trailer as well.
Chances seem good that The Last Jedi will
provide a fitting farewell for her, giving
grieving fans some closure on one of cinema's
most iconic characters, and one of Hollywood's
most beloved actresses.
Delivering on the title’s promise
Towards the end of the trailer, Luke offers
a cryptic confession, saying he only knows
one truth:
"It's time for the Jedi to end."
While fans have been speculating about the
movie title's significance since it was first
announced, the trailer seems to be giving
us a definitive idea about what it'll mean.
The Jedi as we've known them aren't going
to be reborn with Rey.
Rather, their time is coming to an end.
It's also important to keep in mind that not
everyone who practiced the Light side of the
Force was a Jedi, as little Maz Kanata can
attest.
And let's also not forget that the Jedi weren't
necessarily, like, super awesome, you know?
The Jedi Council's shortsightedness and rigidity
helped turn Anakin Skywalker into Darth Vader,
while allowing the Emperor to take over the
Republic.
And Luke's attempts to start a new bunch of
Jedi led to Ben Solo turning his back on his
family and becoming Kylo Ren.
Suffice it to say, the end of the Jedi might
not be such a bad thing…
"Here's some money, go see a Star War."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.